WRONG LETTER INTO A DATABASE.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT FOR IT WHAT
YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> TUCKER, THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME.
THE SYSTEM THAT FAILED AND
RESULTED IN THE FDA GROUNDING
THE FDA FRONTING ALL THOSE
FIGHTS IS 30 YEARS OLD AND
INCENTIVE FOR AN UPDATE FOR
ANOTHER SIX YEARS.
AS TRAPPED IN AIRPORT YESTERDAY
FOR SEVERAL HOURS AND FROM THE
GOING TO TAKE LONGER TO GET BAC
TO MY FAMILY BUT WHEN I WAS
THINKING ABOUT THIS CLEARLY, I
WAS FILLED WITH A WARM FUZZY
FEELING BECAUSE OUR
TRANSPORTATIONS OUR IS MARRIED
TO A MAN WHO BELIEVES THAT ROAD
OUR RACIST SO ALL OF THIS IS
ACTUALLY PROGRESS EXCEPT IT'S
NOT, CHANGE IS NOT THE SAME
THING AS PROGRESS OBVIOUSLY.
WE ARE WITNESSING THE THIRD OF
U.S. INFRASTRUCTURE AND MAY YOU
PETE IS THE IDEAL GUIDE TO
OVERSEE THIS DECLINE.
HE HAS ALL OF THE RIGHT
CREDENTIALS UNDER THE RUBRIC OF
LIBERALISM.
HE HAS ALL OF THESE IMPORTANCE,
BUT ULTIMATELY MEANINGLESS
CREDENTIALS STAPLED TO HIS GOOF
FOUR HEAD.
PETE BUTTIGIEG DOES NOT ASK
QUESTIONS WHEN THEY WANT TO AND
WHEN THEY CAN'T PUT AIRPLANE
SAFELY AND THIS GUY, HE ALSO HA
ALL THE RIGHT AT HAND, HE IS
READY TO SAY A WHOLE LOT OF
NOTHING.
>> Tucker: IT'S WEIRD THAT
PEOPLE PUT UP WITH A SPIRIT IT'
YOU GOT ALL YOUR FREAKING
THEORIES ABOUT CHANGES OR
WHATEVER, BUT YOU HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THE PLANES DON'T CRASH AND
THEY CAN TAKE UP IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
THE POWER GRID WORKS, PEOPLE
SHOULD NOT PUT UP WITH A DEDRIC
OCCASION AND THE BASICS ARE THEY
?
>> AT THINK BECAUSE WE'VE GOTTE
USED TO THIS.
IT SEEMS LIKE INERTIA.
IT'S NOT JUST HAPPENING ON THE
LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT THINK BACK
TO THE SUMMER OF ST. GEORGE
FLOYD CITIGROUP HEARD ONE OF TH
SLEAZIEST ORGANIZATIONS AND THE
WORLD REHABILITATED THE
REBRANDED ITSELF NOT BY CHANGIN
STRUCTURALLY LIKE YOU SAID, YOU
EXPECT AN ORGANIZATION LIKE THA
TO CHANGE STRUCTURALLY, INSTEAD
THEY JUST CAME OUT AGAINST
RACISM AND SUDDENLY PEOPLE STOP
DEMANDING CHANGE AND THEY
SETTLED FOR A CITY OF ROSE IT
OPPOSES RACISM AND THAT'S GOOD
ENOUGH FOR ME.
GET THAT IS SO TRU